remember when the internet was fun when
it was new remember memes and cat videos
and mashups
remember when it felt like hope and
change
i first got online in the ancient days
of the last century i've been making the
internet and making movies about the
internet ever since
i used to think putting the internet
into people's hands was a recipe for
freedom and democracy
it didn't turn out that way
now the internet companies are huge and
they don't act like our friends
shady hackers harvested our attention
subverted democracy and we treated the
cat videos for nazi memes
the internet got old
and kind of boring
and so did
i these days it feels like it's me
versus the screens and the screens are
winning the internet stole all of our
attention
it's sneaky that way
you wake up one day with a smart
toothbrush
your family's exercise is recorded in
the cloud and your refrigerator is
talking to your phone
how did we get here
i feel like we're living in a time where
anything that isn't connected to the
internet is about to be
i still think the internet has a higher
purpose
but it's getting harder every day to
keep the faith
my name is brett and i'm on a mission to
understand the new internet
the internet of everything
[Music]
cs let's get nerdy
[Music]
the consumer electronics show is
america's biggest gadget showcase hello
what is this so this is an automatic
toilet is this connected to the internet
yes
what is it it's a smart particular
system does it connect to the internet
yes obviously
does this connected diaper connect to
the internet yes it will tell you the
moisture
and
this year's biggest trend the connected
home
what you'll see over here is our sense8
kitchen faucet
it's activatable
touchlessly it's activatable manually um
and then now also via voice so consumers
can use apple google um or amazon to
turn the faucet on and off and then also
just cool
we wanna show you our nume 2.0 toilet so
we talked a little bit about intelligent
toilets your amazon alex is actually
embedded into this product you spend
time in this space use amazon alexa
while you're in here to set the mood
play the music change those lights that
you just saw so all the capability of
alexa built right into the toilet as
well
usually this is not a place where i want
the internet to be right
why have you guys put the internet in
the toilet not necessarily meant for you
to have to use it while you're on the
toilet it's meant to use while you're in
this space ah so that's the way that you
bring the microphone into that room is
via the toilet alexa and the google
homes haven't been at microphones
already i'm just giving it to them in a
more seamless experience and also kind
of a use case that makes sense can you
tell the microphone to not be on of
course you can always turn the
microphone off just like you can do with
amazon and with google okay
i get it a microphone in my toilet is
the latest example of tech companies
trying to make themselves indispensable
that's why they need to make all the
dumb objects inside my home smart
open can
at ces really what you have is google
and amazon going against each other with
their smart assistants trying to prove
whose smart assistant has the most
utility which one it can be in the most
devices like billions of devices and
who's really going to win out the smart
assistant wars
these companies have a whole new vantage
point into your life
it's a computer in your bedroom it's a
computer in your living room it's a
computer that's listening
it's a computer you talk to it's a
computer you're friends with
why google or amazon would want
to
build those seems totally obvious to me
the business of google is not a search
engine the business of google is knowing
as much about you as they can know
it seems like yesterday that i was
surfing the web and google was just
trying to help me catch a wave
now it's a mega corporation monetizing
my bathroom
who knows what the consequences of
connecting our homes to the internet
will be but it's happening anyway
wikipedia says that by 2020 aka now 30
billion devices will join what is known
as the internet of things the pizza
delivery drone
it's the inevitable result of computers
getting smaller and smaller
you start with industrial computers
computers were incredibly expensive
there'd be one at mit that everyone
would share
then computers got cheaper people
started getting them in their houses
then you got mobile phones and
that
really meant that humans were for the
first time completely
tractable online
and then the internet of things is
getting all of the electrical products
in your house online it's
if there's something that has
electricity it's going to be wi-fi
connected and that's the internet of
things
the internet of things is like a
never-ending gold rush
there's limitless possibilities when
you're on a mission to connect
everything on earth it's a bonanza for
silicon valley
[Music]
is san francisco as good as everyone
says it is yeah
the companies that are shaping our
country and our world for better and for
worse are made here uber airbnb facebook
google these aren't made in brooklyn
these are made in san francisco
if you're a 22 year old you want to make
your fortune in america
you come to silicon valley
i mean the internet of things is
successful because
it makes life more convenient and humans
are willing to give up all sorts of
things for a
modicum of convenience
a hint of what my fellow nerds would
bring to market in the next few years i
went to an investor pitch day we kind of
see uh the most interesting stuff in the
connected spaces being things that
sort of improve whatever process they're
part of because of the access to data so
whether that's a health tech product
that helps you understand overall
patterns in your own health and other
people's health or whether it's a
product that helps in an industrial
manufacturing process anything where
there's kind of a trojan horse into a
larger world we find really interesting
every startup i met was connecting
something to the internet for the very
first time
one of them was aiming to collect data
from inside a human body
this
a small kegel device that vibrates and
while you're exercising your pelvic
floor
the kick is sensing the data about your
intimate hold and your fertility so this
data is pulled into our cloud you get a
fertility result but you also can export
it and connect to the fertility
specialist it's very cool fitbit for
your vagina
so this is a healthy woman
here is when she was ovulating
and this is the window where she was
able to come see her best time was like
here then we have a woman that has
problems with hormonal balance her
chances of conception are actually lower
and her fertility window is much shorter
there's like a huge disconnect between
the real data what is happening in you
in science and then it's like a lot of
nonsense
so like really help a lot of women
half of my team are women electrical
engineers
so every time we make something we
immediately test what's it like to be a
female founder in a such a geeky kind of
world
okay that's terrible
why
uh
because i'm
it's okay the market is huge
but
pitching
man investor is product for vaginas it's
very challenging how long did it take
you to make a life
days today's eight months
hold on
has a line been crossed here
should the human body be off limits to
the internet
christina's startup is certainly pushing
these boundaries along with a steady
stream of wearables implants and other
devices joining the internet of things
companies are measuring our heart rate
our breathing
our sleeping
we send this data to our phones into the
cloud
once it's in the cloud it becomes a
resource
companies can decide how they want to
use it
and some of them sell it
data brokers is a huge industry in the
united states gathering all this
information and then selling it
traditionally it's been used for
marketing and advertising but now it's
being used more and more in the
healthcare space and in the health
insurance space they are ranking you and
scoring you based on
their algorithm's definition of whether
or not your lifestyle leads to healthy
habits or unhealthy habits you know if a
woman buys plus size clothing online
they predict that she's more overweight
and more likely to be depressed
therefore more likely to have high
health care costs that could lead to
people paying higher rates
there's a proliferation of devices you
know that can track our health
information but the technology has moved
beyond where the law is to actually put
protections in place for consumers and
so the data can be used in a lot of ways
that people would never even imagine
that it would be used
this is eric
he has sleep apnea and uses a cpap
machine to sleep at night
that i snore really really loudly and i
keep my wife up
so in order for that not to happen
i have this really ugly machine that i
put on my face and that blows air into
it just like a horrible thing but you do
it for love
but what eric didn't know was that his
insurance company was recording his
snores
secretly monitoring if he was using the
device properly then they called him up
oh
it says you haven't been compliant
and i said well what do you mean i
haven't been compliant what does that
mean
and she said well it looks like you've
only used the mask for like three hours
on tuesday
and four hours on wednesday and that's
when the like record stopped for me
poor eric the insurance company used his
data against him his private american
health care denied him coverage for a
new mask because the data showed he
wasn't using the machine properly
let me get this straight the reason
you're not giving it to me is because i
haven't been compliant
and the reason i haven't been compliant
is you're not giving me the thing that
you need to give me
i'm just like
this is the reason why we started keg
cake is the only patent-pending device
consumer device which is tracking
vaginal environment for fertility so the
device take the fertility data and they
are also looking for how to use our data
for the future of the research because
as you can imagine we are collecting
also the data that we don't know now
what they could be useful for because
fertility doctors are going to hate you
the winner of our session is keg
[Applause]
the people who want this data the most
are our users you know they want to know
their health data
so we will probably try to just
elaborate every model so we can monetize
there
but
i would try to avoid selling some third
parties if possible because
you know like
what do they they will create a crazy
insurance model for women who are at
risk amazing you know like you don't
really want that say more about that you
don't want
to create a disadvantage for someone in
a whole system just because you have
their data
you know electric toothbrush it knows
how often you're brushing your seat so
it knows you know how likely you are to
get like something wrong with your teeth
which then affects your insurance rate
so this is this is what i'm talking
about and when you have a woman which is
which will have fertility problems and
she is true would you want her to have
like higher insurance i don't like i
personally i don't
living in the future is weird and
confusing
i like what christina is doing
but i do wish she had some legal guard
rails
we don't really know the worst case
scenarios with the internet until after
they happen
and it always seems like something
that's convenient for one person turns
into a nightmare for someone else
so my name is ferial negim and i'm a
survivor
of domestic violence and specifically
also tech abuse
my abuser he utilized our smart home
against me and used it as a means of
control and harassment
everything could be controlled by these
apps so he didn't even actually have to
be in my presence he could be out of the
country thousands of miles away with
this tech abuse the way that he was
utilized the house against me was really
through sleep deprivation
and that sleep deprivation really added
an extra layer to the mental anguish
that was going through i would be asleep
dead asleep at one o'clock in the
morning for instance and all of a sudden
the audio system just blares
up this horrific violent music you're
shocked awake
it is scary because it's pitch black
and i would turn on the lights of course
and
go to the ipad and try to turn off the
system and he would then either switch
the lights on and off he would flicker
the tv on and off he would turn the
audio on and off
that would occur not for a few minutes
like four five six hours
this is used as a tool
to harass you to stalk you within your
home
it's hard
it's hard even with all the trauma work
that i've done
it's it it's triggering because it takes
you back to that night it takes you it
takes me back to those moments of
where i felt hopeless
i felt hopeless
we're all giving up
some of our autonomy and human power to
these devices
always constantly every day
reporting on
situations of domestic violence with
smart home technology made me realize
how bad it could get
things do feel pretty bad
and it's not just me
while i was making this film our
relationship to the internet and its
makers reached an all-time low
even internet executives were feeling
guilty
we have created tools that are ripping
apart the social fabric of how society
works
i would be ashamed if i were you and
that was a big mistake
and it was my mistake i feel tremendous
guilt
and i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm really
[Music]
the internet a scientific breakthrough
is punished
by
the gods
smart cities will pollute with sensors
all joined together by the internet of
things your mattress will monitor your
nightmares your fridge will beat for
more cheese click by click tap by tap
data computer says yes or computer says
no
what will it mean pink eyed terminator
sent back in the future to cull the
human race
what is going on
we're living through this painful
transition caused by the internet and if
history is any guide things are only
going to get weirder
jeremy rifkin has studied other times of
massive change
he sees a pattern in these apocalyptic
times of digital disruption
what we're really talking about here is
a digital revolution across all of
society around the entire planet so we
need to understand the
the full
implications of what this is all about
and the best way to do that is step back
and ask how do these great technological
shifts in history occur
at a moment of time three defining
technologies
will emerge
over a civilization and converge
first new communication technologies to
more efficiently
manage our economic and social life
second new sources of energy more
efficiently power economic life social
life and governance
and third new modes of mobility and
logistics to more efficiently move our
economic social life and governance so
in those rare points in history where
new communication revolutions
converge with new energy regimes
and new modes of mobility and logistics
it transforms the way a civilization
organizes its collective life
according to ripken the first industrial
revolution was caused by a new source of
energy coal
which powered a new communications
medium the steam-powered press
and a new logistics infrastructure in
the railway
locomotives national transport hub to
hub traffic
we got the first major industrial urban
centers
and
our business models move to market
capitalism
second industrial revolution united
states another convergence of
communication energy and mobility that
changed everything
the telephone try to imagine for the
first time in history in the late 19th
century people are picking up this
little device
and their voice is traveling virtually
over thousands of miles at the speed of
light
and then later radio and television
those communication technologies in the
us converge with a new source of energy
the texas oil wells came in
and then henry ford put out that cheap
internal combustion engine powered by
that oil
we went from national markets
to the build out of global markets
it changed our way of life
the last two revolutions left us a world
powered by oil it's led us to the
largest crisis we've ever faced
the second industrial revolution is
fading away
i think we kind of smell it you can feel
it we are now on the cusp of a third
industrial revolution
we're 30 years into the world wide web
3.5 billion people are connected
digitally in their communication that
communication internet
that's now connected human race is just
now converging with a renewable energy
millions of people are producing their
own solar and wind and what they're not
using they're sending back on an
increasingly digitalized power grid
thesis is that communications and energy
are already online and when autonomous
vehicles connect to smart roads and
urban infrastructure via the internet
the third revolution will be complete
internet digital renewable energy
internet digital the mobility internet
digital to manage power and move economy
and society
they ride on top of a platform
and that's the internet of things
we don't need to wait for self-driving
cars to see how the way we move things
has been changed
shenzhen is the city the internet built
anytime you order anything electronic
from amazon you've set off a chain of
events that would have passed through
here the washon bay market
90 of the world's electronics come
through shenzhen and that's why this
former fishing village went from 30 000
people to 12 million in 30 years
it's central to chinese tech companies
like tencent alibaba and huawei
this is not a shopping mall on steroids
it's part of the world's most advanced
electronics supply chain
each one of these booths is actually the
front office of a factory on the
outskirts of shenzhen
the moment i check out my order the
internet connects me to this factory
and if you're making a new device for
the internet of things there's nowhere
faster than shenzhen
in this market you'll find every piece
necessary to build whatever you can
dream up
it's why christina joined the
never-ending parade of startups who come
to shenzhen and prototyped keg i came to
shenzhen because can quickly quickly
quickly prototype so for example when
you do a prototype in the united states
it takes ages to get anything ordered a
pcb made pcb assembled but here you can
do everything in one day
really new like for example this subway
station a year ago it was not here they
were not open yeah they're like moving
super fast
china is quickly moving to become the
leading nation of the third industrial
revolution
this is not well known in the west but
china's leadership began to realize that
co2 was a big problem the chairman of
the national electricity group the state
grid announced a massive multi-billion
dollar effort now operation on the the
new five-year plan to digitalize that
entire
utility grid
put it in place generate their own
energy and share what they don't need
back to the grid full like that they're
putting out millions of electric
vehicles right now millions right now
over the next few years they're already
in production
it's hard not to be impressed by china's
speed
but the implications for connecting an
entire society go beyond smart energy
grids and can be well creepier
chinese cities now collect data from
millions of surveillance cameras from
public transit and from sensors embedded
in street lights and fieldwork
data about where people are and what
they're doing
if you live in hangzhou you are part of
an experiment in modifying the behavior
of citizens known as social credit
[Music]
a
foreign
so how black mirror is this
you get points for being good
saving carbon giving to charity and
exercising
you can trade in your karma points for
free stuff
but the chinese government has put 13
million citizens on a blacklist using
systems like this
marked as dishonest for jaywalking being
late on alone or anything else deemed
antisocial
those users can be blocked from flying
registering for insurance or buying a
house
tying it all together is a payment
system created by alibaba that has
completely replaced cash
its algorithm examines your purchases to
determine trustworthiness
it's kind of like if amazon was your
bank
how do we ensure that governments
don't prolong this internet of things
third industrial revolution
and use it to hack the elections of
other governments that's already
beginning to happen how do we ensure
that internet companies whether it be
facebook or google or amazon or alibaba
don't monopolize this internet for
commercial purposes commodify the
lifetime value of all of our personal
experiences and our data then sell them
to others and then commodify us and
actually through algorithm governance
actually guide our lives that's already
happening
algorithms have begun to play a role in
the governing of cities in north america
as well
vancouver was the first city in canada
to deploy predictive policing
artificial intelligence analyzes data
about past crimes predicts where crime
might happen next and sends cops to
prevent it the main driver that
motivated us to even go down this route
was
a significant increase in property crime
as you can see just in this first
quarter we went from 647 residential
breaking interest in first quarter
we rolled out predictive policing april
1st
by
the beginning of the end of first
quarter the beginning of second quarter
we dropped to 438 residential break and
enters
that number is the lowest number of
residential break and enters we have
going back 30 years of data
so when we load this up
this shows the active forecast
one two three four five six seven eight
houses
pretty much one of them out of these uh
out of these six locations will probably
observe something suspicious
does this actually work
yeah you saw the numbers
so but at any given time if the police
officer goes there they have a 30 to 60
chance they will actually prevent that
yeah you have to have cops everywhere
on all those locations that rotate every
uh two hours
we're just coming up on to mcgill street
off of mcgill
so we're literally right in the
forecasted location right now
drop them brake laners in the middle of
the day
yes
yeah you'd be surprised between two to
four you actually get quite a few i do
want to clear that stuff and we are
heading back to me looking for anybody
that
looks like they would be casing a place
this is algorithmic policing and that's
what we're talking about is all it's the
advent of algorithmic policing
permeating into
everything we do
vancouver police are seeing results
after only a year
los angeles has had systems like this
for far longer
and it's producing some unintended
consequences
the 50 blocks that comprise la's skid
row are one of the most heavily policed
areas of the united states
this 50 block neighborhood is where many
of the 48 000 homeless people in the
city live
it's also home to the stop lapd spying
coalition who have been opposing
predictive policing since 2009.
one of the ways to speak about
data-driven policing is
that
certain communities are very much
over-represented in this data so in
essence it creates a feedback loop of
the same you know just deployment of
policing in these communities skid row
lies next to some of la's most valuable
real estate it's bordered by the arts
district and the downtown core
layered on top of the entire city of los
angeles is an algorithm called pred pool
systems like pred pool analyze crime
data to produce a series of 150 square
meter hot spots around the city that
determine where police officers patrol
whenever someone reports suspicious
activity the algorithm collects that
data so right now we're standing right
here
right yeah so we filed for public
records to see like okay so what were
the hotspots that the hot spots were on
the periphery on the outer boundaries of
skid row so you have the gentrifiers who
are moving in they see somebody from
skid row walk into the neighborhood and
immediately they call the cops so that's
a call for service that there's a
suspicious person in my neighborhood so
the the the whole idea is to create this
whole digital boundary
where somebody walks in from schedule
and goes across los angeles street where
there's hipster veil and bars and
everything else they're going to be
thrown up against the wall they're going
to be harassed and intimidated and
basically given a ticket be contained
and contained
i've been a resident in skid row for uh
15 and a half years so i've been around
a long time i've seen uh
i've seen it evolve we're in a situation
where this incredibly valuable land
uh is desired by gentrifying developers
what pisses me off the most about this
entire situation is a dehumanizing
criminalization of the homeless
do you think these predictive policing
programs are part of it
yes
yes absolutely
vancouver has its own skid row downtown
east side
one of the city's oldest and most
resilient neighborhoods
have survived some of the highest rates
of addiction and mental illness in
canada
targeting residents with algorithms
isn't going to help anyone
so what do we do we actually force the
system
if it
gonna generate a forecast there we force
it to go outside of there and take the
next best one because we do not want
that to occur we don't want to
have a police
military occupation within areas that
obviously have
social societal issues how do you
introduce ethics into a system like that
you can't and that's one thing with
machine learning it's impossible to
build in an ethical subroutine into
machine learning it deals with the
parameters that a human has decided it
should examine and then you tell it what
its end objective is like there's a lot
that can be done with ai
and i think kind of one question you
should ask yourself
at a human level is
should we be doing it and i'm not sure
that question gets asked a lot of the
time and
if you kind of look at it
and something you're doing has a creepy
factor to it
i don't think we should be doing it
creepy
would it feel creepy to live inside a
neighborhood created by a company in the
business of surveilling you
google's parent company is called
alphabet
alphabet owns a company called sidewalk
labs
in 2017 alphabet's eric schmidt traveled
to canada and proposed sidewalk labs
built a neighborhood in toronto from the
internet up
wouldn't it be nice if you could take
technical things that we know and apply
them to cities all of these things that
we could do if someone would just give
us a city and put us in charge
it's no joke they've proposed a city
that bakes in the internet
but try and google what it will look
like and all you'll find are images that
look like 1970s science fiction covers
the only thing that's clear is that the
internet will be in everything and that
google's sister company is in full-on pr
mode
you can increase the
green space
the density
sidewalk toronto is a new type of
complete community here in the
waterfront in toronto okay and so what
we're looking at here is how new
technologies can try to make cities
better for people
you're looking right now at a street
that has a configuration for two lanes
of traffic that's probably actually too
much for a street of this wind so you
could imagine um maybe on the weekend
you want to use it like a plaza so the
street turns white you block off the
edges in red
or maybe in the morning it becomes a
bike highway so you have bike lanes that
might
tell you directions and then a crosswalk
to keep people
moving
the concept that's emerging is for an
adaptive city that can respond
intelligently to signals collected about
weather traffic and people
have the city be more kind of responsive
in real time i think is really exciting
and something that data can make make
happen so do you feel like you
would offer
information about where you were to have
the city respond to you in in a way i
don't want to be
you know having big brother
look behind my back all the time i i
would really dislike that so so it's a
very fine line of
you know how much data i would want to
share or the way in which the data is
shared
any data that we would ever collect is
only for the intent of actually like
making the place better for people and
being very thoughtful from the beginning
of how do we really preserve everyone's
privacy throughout the entire process
well it'll vary based on any of the
types of things that we're talking about
the magician wants you to look at their
hands but what's going on
over there
the hands right now is like let's talk
about buildings or gadgets or autonomous
vehicles or whatever else what's going
on you know where no one's looking for
the most part is that there's an inf
there's an enabling infrastructure being
built
for everything for the physical spaces
for the home for all of it i mean it
basically puts the entire world it
blankets it in
in what's what what enables the big tech
companies business models cities are
going to collect more and more data
about us and there's nothing necessarily
wrong with that
data can make our cities better
in the 1800s a scientist named jon snow
stopped an outbreak of cholera by
putting a data point on a map every time
someone died of the disease combining
data with the map showed that
contaminated water pumps were the
culprit
the fight over data in our cities isn't
just about privacy it's about
privatization
in the same way that tech companies
found a way to monetize our bathrooms
connecting our cities to the internet
opens up even more possibilities for
business imagine the next uber wants to
pay more for the curbs where the most
people are standing or a new startup
wants to direct you to the next free
park bench in exchange for ads and your
location data of course
this process has always been framed of
how to make a test bed in the portlands
the question should be
do we want a test bed in the portlands
do people want to be
having a test bed in a neighborhood
where people will live is that a concept
that anybody here in the room remembers
signing off on
look at the state of the internet there
has been a massive centralization of
both its infrastructure and then the
companies that are basically the
backbone of the internet so to take
those things and replicate them in the
physical world to me it's like you are
going the wrong way
are we privatizing
municipal infrastructure services our
public assets and no one has answered me
it's all we're working on it we're
working on it seems to me before we talk
about what they build on the site these
are the questions that should have been
answered in day one
not in the final
you know technology and computer science
nothing about those things is inherently
capitalist
right governments can empower themselves
with those tools and they can have a
public service that knows how to use
these tools
and and build that capacity up in
government
even with all the pushback sidewalk labs
planned seemed inevitable
are there only two choices for the city
of the future
a surveillance state or corporate
experiment
[Music]
barcelona is navigating a middle path
becoming a leader in the design of smart
cities rejecting corporate control of
data and making the state accountable to
citizens
for us data is like another public
infrastructure like water
like electricity like roads like the air
we breathe and so this data needs to
be a common good for our citizens
we want to move away from surveillance
capitalism and enter in a digital
economy where data is a common good and
we can have collective actions where
people are aware of what happens with
their data and how they can maximize the
benefit of the digital society
in barcelona data serves the people
take the smart citizen initiative it's a
simple sensor that's 3d printed locally
and distributed freely
sensors were installed around the city
to collect data about co2 emissions
pollution and noise citizens then
pressured city council to enforce quiet
zones
smart citizen is a project of fab lab
barcelona
the machines and the people here turn
information into things bits into atoms
instead of just writing a white paper
about how we think that the smart city
could be
we said okay let's make a project out of
it let's make an experiment let's build
something we're a fablab we know how to
build things so we can think about ideas
but also build them and test them we'll
make tools for data collection we'll
make tools for data sharing and we'll
see how we engage people into that
if you can make almost anything in a
fablab then you can make the things that
make almost anything in a fabulous right
so you can make machines that make
machines that make machines you can
instead of shipping
you know smartphones from china you can
actually make them locally
in every city
you can design something in barcelona
and it could be made anywhere in the
world so you don't have to move
materials
you move information
in 2014 barcelona made an audacious
pledge
everything the city needed would be
produced locally within 40 years
clothes cars bones everything
i want barcelona to be the leading city
in the new industrial revolution
[Music]
what we are doing in the fab city
project which is you know have this
large mission on making cities to
produce locally what they consume by
2054
is trying to align these fablabs as a
backbone kind of resource in order to
start the transition to local production
in cities but at the same time operating
it as a distributed and open network
worldwide so we right now have 28 cities
that have pledged to the challenge that
we start we launched in barcelona in
2014 the mission is very clear let's try
to make sure that we can live in this
planet without compromising our future
anyone can join the fablab network
online their belief is that by producing
locally they'll reduce the waste and
carbon cost of shipping materials around
the world it's an urgent mission
anastasia joined to invent new materials
that can be created sustainably
so
they are different materials
and if you want to do one of them you
just follow the recipe and these are the
ones with the food waste so these ones
are with coffee grains
and this one with orange peels
can this replace plastic
yes
in 20 years what do you want this to
change everybody talks about fast
fashion why don't we make super fast
fashion it's even faster you know like
because people they want to be consumers
so
you say okay
then if you want to consume maybe there
is a vending machine that is selling you
a bioplastic t-shirt
you can wear your bioplastic t-shirt
like cinderella
and then you can just throw it but not
feel so guilty about it then at least
make it so that it is something that is
not harming the planet
yeah
[Music]
to realize the fab city vision for
cities to be self-sufficient in 40 years
we're going to need to figure out how to
make food and have a new relationship
with nature
the green fab lab was set up in
barcelona's central park to get started
going from how to make almost anything
to how to grow almost anything
self-sufficiency
in materials in production
in food production
energy and water
it's about understanding what we can
consume and what we produce
the fab labs are wonderful places to
create
and to have
the power of production
in your hands
so when i came here i saw the fablab
barcelona and i thought this is the
place for me
because it allows me to to engage in my
own projects and to do so at
quite an advanced level
building on smart citizen jonathan and
friends created open source beehives
from the buzzing sounds inside the hive
software translates this data so
beekeepers can monitor the health of the
bees
you can download all of the files
and you can put that onto a cnc machine
and make one yourself
a little bit like an ikea kit
and you can mount it yourself no screws
no glues
you just bang it together
bees are losing their habitat
and
they're being managed highly managed
and so it's kind of interesting to just
let them do what they would want to do
observe them
not try and maximize their production
but work with them
in a little bit more
in a slower way
when i set out to discover how the
internet was evolving i don't think i
imagined i'd be squatting in the dirt
looking at a beehive
it's crazy
but it's probably less crazy than the
internet of things would seem to anyone
alive 30 years ago
we are at the beginning of something
somebody looks at this beautiful place
in the mountains in the middle of
barcelona they would say that's
too small to power an entire city is
this a hint of what
it looks like in the future the hardest
part of of the transformations that
we i believe we are part of is not to
envision the next 50 years uh or the
next 40 years in the case of fab city
which is actually what happens in the
next two years like how how do we start
how the transition looks like we have
been only using oil in like a
very infinite part right so
um yes uh you know we can ambition a
future without oil
the problem is start to building it now
uh and
and and i think that's
that's the main challenge we need to
build the transition not and i think
that it's enough of building like uh
visions of the future frameworks and
pledges and desperation yeah seeing that
that's enough it's just an excuse to
have a timeline but now it's about
building it sometimes i listen to myself
and
it's like this is so naive like what are
you saying but it's like at the same
time it's like a but what what other
alternative i have can make it happen
[Music]
in the early days of the internet there
were no business models no users to
capture no data to mine
the purpose of the web was written right
across its first logo
just the words let's share what we know
[Music]
what i saw in barcelona was the first
step towards people using that
invitation to share knowledge to solve
the biggest problems before us
[Music]
the un panel on climate change says we
now
have 11 years to transform the entire
world we're in a disaster mode from here
on in
anyone who believes this is the age of
progress that's history this is the age
of resilience
can we do this in a few years we laid
out the entire first industrial
revolution in 30 years it can be done in
20 years
but we now have to wake up
and that's where this digital revolution
will help
if christina stays true to her mission
she has the power to change millions of
women's lives for the better
and her promise to do right by their
data could actually be more profitable
than selling them out entering mass
production in china she gained something
to keep her honest that she didn't have
before
users
this is my cake
i'm not going to
so i have the kick app right here this
is my graph
i think christy will succeed because the
world
is uh comprised of 51 of women
and there is so little investment in our
health
because knowledge is power right
i don't have time to wait around and uh
gets pregnant god knows when i'm already
39 i have no time to waste
christina launched a crowdfunding
campaign that sold out in less than two
days she had enough orders to bypass
amazon and sell directly to the women
who needed her product women who had
made their reservations on our waiting
list is around 4 000 people right now
within few weeks so it's quite crazy
the other alternative you have on the
market right now it looks like this it's
crazy
good luck
technology is neither good nor bad nor
neutral especially the internet
we can use it to make things in new ways
or we can make things that use us
on the upside
big leap forward potentially for
humanity
because we can now envision
the whole human race
connecting with each other virtually and
physically
everywhere at every moment across the
earth
we're bringing the human family together
our generation this moment will be
looked back on as
an enormous turning point for humans
like now that we're all connected
now the real story starts
i think we are the child of the internet
you know what i mean the other internet
hasn't disappeared
it's there but we are just looking
somewhere else
just pressure start shooting
wishing for the internet of my youth is
kind of bad parenting
because that internet isn't going to do
these guys any good
it's like complaining about how cool the
telegraph was
all this worry about the internet really
is old school
because for them
it's just life
where did you get those images
you know on google yeah
what i would say to the person who
says the internet is gonna ruin the
world i would say
you may be right but i hope you're not
right
i hope so too kid
maybe my internet is getting old and
boring
but your internet can be anything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything
[Music]
everything everything
[Music]
[Music]
everything
everything everything everything
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
[Music]
everything everything everything
everything everything everything
[Music]
what
is
everything
[Music]